I know I know yeah because you've
corrupted our little sister and I have a
theory about friends friends is like
cilantro you genetically either love it
or hate it like there is a DNA trait
that you have that makes you either love
friends or it'll make you question every
no it's like to yell stab there is no
illegitimate friend have a question for
you have you ever seen an episode which
one Massapequa since you got upset and I
only could tolerate the episode because
Alec Baldwin was being hilarious but the
rest of the of the friends are garbage
and then I was like a snitch yesterday
she was watching an episode where
Rachael once become a smoker for the dog
oh yeah yeah yeah and like I just I just
was staring at Margo the whole time to
make sure she didn't laugh no but here's
the thing you can never even attempt to
like it because you have you're being
stubborn like you're being martyred no
like there was a time when I really was
so open-minded because you talked about
it so much on the show that it wouldn't
be who've me yeah to like it but it is
such garbage it's crazy and I can't
believe that you guys like like it it's
cilantro I'm Caleb Nichol and I hate
cilantro
I hate cilantro and I understand what
you're saying I don't hate Sondra but I
hate I just feel as if you've never all
people who like cilantro also I don't
like friends and hate cilantro because
you hate it you like friends I don't
like I like cilantro and I don't like
friends so I'm just gonna go out on a
limb like my sketch or sneakers but I
love I'm gonna go out on a limb and say
there's absolutely no correlation
between the two but then again then
again what do I know about genetics I'll
be testing people well I got Margo went
to friends and it's the greatest thing
to ever happen also cuz it's a great
show to travel with it's like every time
you're in a hotel room it's always on
like Nick at night or TBS or some [ __ ]
so it's nice to have a show that you can
just watch even if you've seen every
episode like you've really never seen
why does she keep saying pivot it's a he
watched his friends it's a joke because
she want to know what I know so when
Ross gets a new couch she makes them all
carry it up the stairs and they live in
a walk-up and like they literally can't
get his couch up the stairs cuz it's so
narrow and they're almost there that I
turn in the corner on the staircase and
Ross is screaming like in the weirdest
accent he's like pivot he's screaming at
the top of his lungs it's just like a
great part of the episode
there should be show
you recap friends because your
explanations of friends episodes I agree
you make friends sound interesting
because that was a good recap right yeah
and I know anything that matt LeBlanc
what's his character Joey I agree with
you anything that he does he couldn't
say chicken soup in the commercial yes
yeah I agree to eat there don't get me
wrong it's not a perfect show it's not a
perfect show and if I had all the time
in the world I would go into the
intricacies of all the people who were
cast members and the problems it's like
Monica and Ross like there's something
inappropriate about their brother-sister
relationship Joey is anyone really that
stupid no you know and I do I do have
problems with it Rachel like actually
the most annoying human being on the
[ __ ] face of the earth and so on
deserving of Ross's love because Ross
and I people just to be with me for
saying this but and if everyone in the
group I saw your controversial tweet
Ross is the catch he is the doctor
he has only ones to do is start a family
and Rachel's like so put off biting the
fact that he like wants to move to
Westchester and like get married and
start a family it's okay Rachel you're
[ __ ] trash but you want to be a [ __ ]
and like run out of more weddings please
no Ross is a stand-up [ __ ] guy who
just has good values cares about his
family cares about his children like
just once to get married they're always
making fun of him for being the guy who
gets married like very much I'm here for
us okay I'm officially reached my Crona
okay time spent talking to friends
related content right so I understand
Mauro you'll bring me to the I offend
how is the Knicks game oh my god okay I
miss Pete Davidson so yeah I mean to be
honest I have a lot of things I for been
like Ben is always asking me to go to
net games and I just can't like that's
not how I choose to spend my weeknights
like I have limited amounts of time at
home and I just like I find they don't
allow dogs and I just find it so boring
but it's Ben's birthday tomorrow oh my
god I just remembered I have to get a
mint
oh we were shopping today let's do that
and I decided like not only am I going
to get him good seats but like I will
endure the treachery no you look great
so I went and once I got there seeing
PGA meets in like made me feel better
but I got been like really good special
seats like behind the next bench and I
just have to say look what they don't
tell you about those seats like it
smelled so bad like so sweaty and like
at first I was like who smells I'm like
maybe it's the 10 huge sweaty athletes
sitting in front of me I don't know
maybe but it was so smelly and so
torturous so like I literally like I
couldn't stand it and like what they
don't tell you about those really good
courtside seats is that they were really
[ __ ] uncomfortable chairs like that
smoothing chairs the guy next to me was
actually sitting on my lap I literally
sat him like then no there's kind of
smells like hi I'm like do I need my
China like what do you want he was
literally sitting on top me so like it
wasn't a pleasant experience
no I mean it's great yeah and get that
lounge with a phoenix games are always
fun
no one ever invites me I saw a bunch of
toasters and I wouldn't spend my own
money on Knicks tickets because I would
have to care you know I'd rather go to a
concert ya know it's just it's not how I
choose to spend my time but Ben loves it
so much and I know that like when he
goes to this friends he like feels bad
leaving me at home like little does he
know like my time alone with you is the
best time of my life but he doesn't want
to leave so I'm like okay now he puts me
in the position where like I have to go
yeah it was his birthday and I think he
was really happy so I think it did The
Good Wife thing well I'm gonna give you
one more opportunity to join me this
evening at my culinary boot camp so
here's the thing I was going to to join
you cuz in just three weeks time I'll be
a master chef I know and you sent the
link and you're like for anyone who
wants to come and I was gonna do it
until I realized it's a three-hour class
tonight and so I just don't have three
hours to spare like off of my phone I
just think like what I will have to put
in I will get so much out of it yeah for
life like I've just been craving fresh
food that I can make you know like I
even made like a Boca burger last night
with like a piece of cheese and it was
melted like for me the problem like the
reason why I'm not making food at home
it's not because I don't know how to
cook it's cuz I have no food oh well
then you get food like once you know how
to cook yeah but I'm always doing that
grocery delivery and it's like I don't
even live here like ya know it's it's
tough I'm gonna have to figure it out
that's why this is a perfect time to do
it because I'm moving students who then
I'll have all my registry like hands and
then I'll be like I'll be so excited
about the kitchen
totally anyways I'm just really looking
forward to it my new year's my new first
New Year's resolution this year is learn
how to cook and I'm very much making
strides there's nothing like setting
goals and accomplishing them like we
spoke about yesterday and if you don't
say your goals you can never accomplish
them so I'm also gonna say my other goal
for the year which because I'd miss my
resolutions last year I had
blow up this year is to learn how to
drive oh you I'm gonna teach you no I'm
gonna take classes just like I'm taking
like I'm gonna go brew by the book I
have to take that five-hour class and
first I'm going to get the cooking thing
I've the way and then maybe this summer
like you'll see me cruising around town
yeah because it's like you have so many
hopes and dreams and like vision boards
that include you driving like whether
it's a pic of my whole life or
convertible might like my life goals
revolve around me knowing how to drive
so you got to just do it yeah so that's
next okay speaking of summer fun I did
something crazy last time I watched an
episode of summer house okay so I've
actually been like watching it just
because especially when I was in LA I
was every time I was in my green room I
was on delayed Bravo time so I miss
venom from Broyles and was watching
summer house and they just have to say
like it is trash it's trashed but I
think it's gotten better
because you want to kill the girl with
the haircut he's changing the show that
girl is literally like the cutest girl
on the planet wait who are you talking
about another bunch
oh no I disagree the brunette I'm
talking about Lindsey the blonde she cut
her hair right which was just good for
her no because she's like one of the
only people who has stood the test of
time right and she's the only person
who's like honest and calling these
people out for being [ __ ] freaks it's
like they get the weirdest people on
this show and they all pretend like
they're normal people but no Lindsey's
the only one being like I think this
guy's a pathological liar right when t
said the virginity story is yes from a
movie yeah literally like in this show I
I thought you were talking about her
she's like a breath of fresh air that
she's like the only living in reality
well i only watched one episode so I
missed that I saw a clip of that i watch
I was like last night's episode they all
like day party drunk and then also we're
having a party that night and they were
just like so drunk and then Kyle was
like being a drunk like like someone on
their homeworlds just like an [ __ ]
and I've had just watched matter from
barroso is ready for his now fiance to
react like a baby and she was so mature
with him and it's around and it's like
it was it was shocking to see that on TV
like someone who had their stuff
together the summer house show is really
like room because they never leave that
[ __ ] house because they're not
allowed to film anywhere in my talk they
get kicked out all the time for filming
and then when they do they like film on
a blurry cell phone that so only maybe
ever have footage like I have so many
problems with the show because at the
end of the day it's a genius idea like
everyone thinks like the Hamptons all
those people go to the Hamptons Hamptons
having the celebrity rich like
but they've managed to find seven people
who are a uninteresting and B seven
people who have to go back to the city
every Sunday like to have a show that
you can only film two days a week it's
so stupid why don't they get people who
can work remotely want to get bloggers
well they get rich people who don't have
jobs who can actually spend the entire
summer in the Hamptons half an episode
is them carpooling back and forth to the
city I hate doing that in the summer I
don't watch other people doing it right
I totally agree the show is like they
took this good idea and made it the
worst it could ever be in terms of
finding not great cast members and also
finding people who have day jobs yeah I
agree but I I just I think after
watching one episode it's like better
and the girl with the haircut and Karl
are like being really cute and he's so
into her and he was never into anyone I
don't even like Karl
I don't like Karl either but now like
she's not into him which like I totally
get because if she ever watched a show
why would she be anyways I just like her
haircut in her outfit and I just had a
different flavor to summer house one
that I watched an episode of yeah and
they used to be like when I when summer
house came on like I was like of course
I'm watching summer house it's like it's
a battleship it's New York Vanderpump
rules and in that's how it was also
introduced and it was like I couldn't I
couldn't ever watch it like it was so
painful I watched the first step no and
I couldn't ever get through an episode
every week I would watch and I could
never finish an episode last night I
stumbled into an episode and I was like
I found myself watching it mhm
so what's gotten better it was all the
house has gotten Saturday and we had two
good haircuts so yeah that's cute yeah
but it's like not nearly as nice as the
first or the second one oh I don't
remember
because second one was really nice but
they literally go places and get kicked
out that's great it's like a township of
local East Hampton like doesn't want
them there makes sense yeah so I think
they're finally like out in water mill
which is super far yeah eventually
they're gonna be filming like in the
middle of nowhere it's like not even the
Hamptons right they're slowly they're
slowly getting like kicked out of every
Township that they're literally gonna go
to like Fox woods like that's the only
place left yeah it's so funny hilarious
anyways we'll talk about the purple
girls you say you watch yes it doesn't
cool okay but before we do here are the
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast Justin Bieber
faces backlash over April Fool's Day
pregnancy joke obviously he did not
watch the toast yesterday morning and
there he's not in June we are truly like
psychic soothsayers
we're clairvoyant totally some jokes
just aren't funny Justin Bieber took to
Instagram on Monday to announce that his
wife Haley Baldwin was pregnant with the
first child he posted a photo of a
sonogram though many were suspicious
that it was a stock photo and when he
posted that everyone knows April Fool's
Bieber then doubled down and he posted
photos of Baldwin getting examined that
what appeared to be an OBGYNs office
holding her belly quote if you thought
it was April Fool's Bieber said
affirming his wife's pregnancy
eventually Bieber shared another photo
of a sonogram this time with a puppy in
it wait oh my god is that a April Fool's
he wrote followers were in laughing
quote of course Justin Bieber will think
a pregnancy announcement would be funny
anything Bulls especially so when one in
seven women have had a miscarriage you
not to mention those suffering from
infertility we wrote one Twitter user
yeah Twitter's ablaze
Twitter's ablaze but also this is just
something I feel like we've really grown
out of as a generation like we just
don't do this anymore and April Fool's
Day was really annoying yesterday
because a lot of people bloggers
influencers reality stars like we're
hopping on the bandwagon and a lot of
toasters were falling for it and I was
so disappointed by the toaster community
than the group like everyone Luann's
moving up everybody I think that the
worst one was Dorinda oh why she
literally had her hands on the table had
a big engagement ring I was like I love
this ring I do love it like she was
trying so hard not to be subtle like
feel like there was engaged you got
didn't we warn you I don't know say I
didn't say I didn't warn I was really
disappointed like nothing nothing was
fooling me and by glaive someone did
happily did announce me yesterday
they'll have to renounce it today
because okay but I did see one that got
me for like a second
can i it was it something Navy no it was
diet Prada
they said they were selling their
Instagram account for a million dollars
and honestly like that's what it's
probably worth right and I was like damn
I wonder why because it's right it was
so stupid like I really I hope everyone
is grateful that we didn't do that
because I had somebody someone said
something funny that we should have done
yesterday's switch seats and like not
mention it oh that would be a good idea
next year
yeah maybe tell that to us on March 31st
or 30th 30 very suitors
yeah I was I was disappointed yes sir
because just like the day that never
ended but yeah of stupidity it was so
stupid like every time I checked the
toaster scoop I was like another one
bites the dust yeah no I thought
something that means that's kind of
funny it was because it was a semi
believable she said that she was gonna
join our houses in New York I'm like
she's a rich girl who lives in New York
like duh yeah and they're trying to
bring their demographic down she's a
wife I wonder if they've ever reached
out to her I don't know they haven't
reached out to me and that's all I care
about so it's not like they're totally
like telling you say jelly big either
you're gonna say desperate to help me
into the influencer world anyways Justin
Bieber nice try and also it's like the
thing money proposed it's just like huda
beauty you can't start a few days before
and you can't double down you do it once
if people the doubling down the doubling
down and that's an announcement so I'm
like you saying it's not April Fool's
makes it not April Fool's and anyone who
does an April Fool's joke of something
that they're actually gonna want in a
few years like whether it's pregnancy or
like some of my career goals like that
is just a bad omen
April Fool's I learned how to drive okay
that's not like that bad no but it's my
goal but it's like April Fool's I got my
own beauty line no you actually want
that's [ __ ] sad that yeah that's have
April 2nd is gonna be a hard day
emotional yeah cuz it's only
highlighting the fact that you don't
have your own beauty line exactly and
then I want one right take that one
right so very sad there are there rules
when it comes to April Fool's and
honestly we failed yesterday as a
society yeah you guys I just I'm so
disappointed I really I just I really
expected so much motorcylce thought we
were ironclad you know and we were in it
together we're gonna like move like a
school of fish you know and we watching
April Fool's jokes
we had our guards on we were we were
blinded by the light we had a horse
blinders that's the word I can find it
of course funders like Secretariat yeah
okay speaking of sad Poosh has launched
great Segway thank you and instead of
reading you know someone's recap
highlighting the highlights
we're gonna go through the website and
we're gonna read you some of the
headlines and we're gonna get to the
bottom of what this website strives to
be and before you do because I know they
already fixed it I saw in the toasters
group now is that girl's phone oh yes
bad Wi-Fi everyone is like no but
honestly really help was helpful for me
cuz I was able to see the headlines like
straight up like ingredient highlight no
check no ingredients spot eight months
when you know what are the about page Oh
her about page for a while had the
template in which like the website like
you mean you use like WordPress it's
like play something here about your
brand what do you want everyone to know
and she forgot to update the about page
to me like this is Kourtney Kardashian
here and she literally just had like the
template verbiage on it Wow
very sad also my coffee table is coming
today I'm happy for you thank you I'm
happy for you know that I am even if I
can't understand I'll take the pain gay
oh my god I have to tell you something
so I might show this weekend there was a
girls there with their mom and they came
up and like the mom was like a little
mean like she was like a little like
classic like judgmental mom but like I
wasn't her daughter you know right and
she was like she said to me she goes
doing your ego get too big and I was
like wait then the guys the people
behind her they were like mom was so
crazy she was like you know I don't know
if check is as beautiful she looks on TV
I just want to say I'm more beautiful
because I'm like literally it just case
in point you might outfit today is so
cute on this show I look like a sack of
potatoes no totally and it's just I need
people could say what they want about us
but like you're beautiful and I'm
hilarious I didn't even mean to me but
like I literally don't look beautiful on
this show no Tony show does nothing for
me so it was just like this mom was like
coming for us and she was in the fee I
peel and I'm like you are not a VIP
that's crazy and it was just crazy I
came from amazed she said to you I don't
like your ego it's a bigger mic huh what
you listening
well cause like I understand that she
wants to give you critiques while you're
in person maybe sudden airplane - and
she's gonna see you again
like what do I have to do there was this
limited I'm killing for Mara you weren't
even in California she's from Pensacola
that's not much much bigger than
Maysville if you don't know that line is
from an iconic scene in law and order
SVU that I actually auditioned for and I
had a beating when I was in LA and
people are like what do you want like
what your own TV show I'm like I
be an extra in SVU yeah Adam still
that's another career goal of mine so
now I have four Netflix special media
partner for the toast the one that
actually might come true that I don't
want to say and extra just like the
murderer or like dead body [ __ ] no Jew
no heart of this to stand still like not
breathe we tried it once
oh yeah hold on dude we do we hide
shampoos conversation like this okay and
then we said what would you do like also
now act like you found the dead body oh
okay okay so your job be dead okay we
were jogging when we did it let's switch
it up there solo you're on a solo jog oh
okay okay I'm gonna solo jog well that's
highly unrealistic okay just jogging
through it says why it's called acting
surely just jogging through the woods
minding my own business got my ear pods
on a dead body in the woods why is her
tongue out she's come back to life oh my
god honestly though like I just really
think like I would slay it as a murderer
yes yes but you would literally slay
slay all day hey I'm just re back to
push it back to boots so here are some
of the headlines the big story of the
day Kris Jenner on what it takes to be a
boss so and what it takes to be a good
mom is to sit down with your daughter
for this article know what it takes to
be a good mom is to literally do
everything for your aortic daughter
right okay then first on the swirl page
it has a nice format this is giving
Arthur George vibes like just in terms
of the level of sadness
first story how to look good naked
honestly the picture of Courtney click
yeah what are the tips oh let's see this
is in a world of mirror selfies bikini
shots and filters the pressure to look a
certain Instagram bull way are real
thanks to Kourtney Kardashian and her
Photoshop were in the bathtub she's
she's literally the one setting these
unrealistic why she's been right so she
could tell this is vertical integration
like she's making everyone feel insecure
and also telling them how to not feel
you're right we have a question in our
mind like who are we supposed to think
is writing this quote okay well there
are some that are by patient some that
are by Kourtney this one's by Poosh
which means they look an interim yeah if
that's you you're not alone we get it
and with that comes a design
to look and feel a hundred percent we
are wearing well nothing today I feel
like an SNL a yes today we're taking the
stress out of undressing and sharing the
key to looking your best when you're
down to your birthday suit or even brown
undergarments regular workouts and clean
eating aside feeling prime sans clothes
starts with healthy skin which is why
we're focusing on ways to keep your body
hydrated and fresh from head to toe we
already did the intro paragraph where
are the tips yeah here are some tips
help you achieve this okay scrubs
there's no better way to slough off
unwanted dry flaky skin than a powerful
yet safe scrub okay and then there is a
bunch of scrubs body cream bunch of body
creams including lemare obviously and
kapowee oh so obviously she's making
money from other products she's selling
yeah
hydration there's a comply paddle the
way if someone asked me like how does
the best way to look naked like I could
tell you you exfoliate then moisturize
like this is not that complicated get a
spray tan yeah yeah lighting and there's
civil Andals I don't know
someone said Claudia how do you feel
good naked you know what I do oh and
don't forget about this one posture
that's actually true yeah just stand up
straight this is so dumb a sit up wait
she chose to flatten your belly
she took her up and just made it a
website and called it something new and
take a - Instagram talking about phoning
it in ingredient spotlight we're
spotlighting an ingredient okay what
does the ingredient do tumeric look I
don't think I could relate to this
website on any less of a level
must-haves for a relaxing night in
Beyonce's makeup artist on how to get
fuller lips well this is Kylie big Mario
like this is weird her fianc beyond
saying the Kardashians are not on good
terms
yeah non-toxic SPF her face and body
this is so weird this is a Honolulu bleh
makes a great point
this feels counterproductive like she's
already a huge brand with lots of
connections and she's launching a blog
like people start with a blog right yeah
this makes no [ __ ] sense and I mean
not that I was ever gonna like give it
the product not that I would ever be a
push subscribing like this it's just my
SIA yeah it's beautiful I wonder who
made the website so she has kids stuff
decor okay if she had started something
decor oriented like I would have I would
have bought
yeah but it's like she's so she like she
used to be so mean
yes it is Shay Mitchell warming up your
muscles before solid workout shouldn't
be overlooked I want to see one that's
written by Courtney yeah which one go to
the first to go to the top of shredder
and what it takes to be boss by Kourtney
Kardashian oh you're gonna die the
opening line what oh the devil works
hard they say the devil works hard but
we all know Kris Jenner works harder for
my first separate interview for Poosh i
sat down with my mom to pick her brain
up on my first ever interview period I
sat down with my mom to pick her brain
on what it means to be a boss we talked
about how to handle rejection the
importance of a morning routine and a
wine town at the end of the night
spoiler she says a long day always calls
for a vodka drink and what I learned
when I was her assistant watch the video
for wise words of wisdom so she can even
write the interview she filmed it and it
honestly looks like a sad take or
background wait so let me see okay hold
on
I say core is so sad honestly like this
looks like poor like they're gonna talk
and they might take each other's tops
off right it's giving me weird pointy
times it does because like it's poor
audio and lighting it looks like the
only thing that you feel like to
audition but yes make it into the room
or know what didn't at home tape no they
also film you in the room yeah and like
years later it's like watch Leah Michels
Glee audition and that's it
right you see Lea Michele was playing
ariane the mermaid aidid is that one of
the stories no i forgot this iconic
iconic there's nothing to say other than
that this is the greatest thing to ever
happen to us yes and poosh is is not of
the worst not the worst I mean whatever
I hope that like this gives her
something to be passionate about no but
it was so funny cuz when I was born she
wanted to be a big time magazine right
and when I was watching the Kardashians
this week in court Khloe was at her good
American shoot I really realized like
they off so much going on with their
lives like Kourtney actually has nothing
and like that's really what the crux of
the argument last season was about but
like Khloe really has good American
which is a huge brand Kim has 1 million
things her app k'kaw Beauty um Kylie
obviously Mogul City Kris mogul city
even [ __ ] rob has Arthur George
Kendall's one of the biggest models in
the world like Kourtney actually like
doesn't do anything yeah it's really
rides the family coattails not
this feels like very like a knock off
goop right no and it's like here's the
thing whenever I'm starting a brand or
company like you have to answer the
question anyway on Shark Tank like what
does this service provide that people
can't get anywhere what problem does
this solve right and there is nothing
about this I'm sorry mr. wonderful
that's proprietary or that's problem
solving right like what problem like
what question do have to ask myself the
question have to ask myself is its how
does Kourtney Kardashian get ready for a
big night out that's the only way I
would end up here like honestly you know
what would be interesting you want to
know the answer yeah poor glam before
outfit planning there's one ritual
quartz swears by when she's getting
ready for an event or a night out you
ready for it she applies gel patches and
you're kidding me under her eyes for at
least five minutes prior to like every
other woman in America she keeps hers in
the fridge to feel the cooling foot this
is a skinny confidential literally oh my
god honestly I think I already knew
Everts has a case I think she does too
she's coming out is she going next week
and I'm gonna talk to her about this
this is a this is a Vinny confidential
we need to do a side-by-side of all the
articles she's stolen because I put my
job patches in the fridge because
because of Lauren told me I don't know
that I'm gonna oh my god it's incredible
it's a cooling sensation for the eyes oh
we love a cooling sensation before my
makeup she keeps hers in the fridge to
feel the full cooling effect on the
delicate area of the face the beauty of
gel pads is that they help to firm tone
and deep puff your under eye area within
minutes consider adding this step to
your evening prep routine shop a few of
our pics below blogging is annoying
because like I've someone launching in I
just want to see if I click something oh
my god am I being taken into let's say
to our style our style so she's really
using these really it's don't buy the
ladies just gave her a dollar stop no I
didn't buy it she doesn't get she
doesn't get money for free flex just
conversion um I mean you should support
we're here female so supporting
everywhere yeah but here's the thing
there's something about coordinate
Kourtney Kardashian that is interesting
and I'll tell you what it is a few years
ago maybe five years ago when she like
had just given up and she was wearing
all her hair and there was like being
sprayed x' and bangs and she was living
in that house with scott and she seemed
so [ __ ] misery and so unhappy hearing
like too much Allison Olivia yes wasn't
getting at him yeah and it was a hard
time and it seemed as though she had
like just were like given up decided
the Imam you know just going the natural
route like just what he didn't care
that's the path that she chosen and then
something happened when she broke up
with Scott where she really got her
groove back yeah and I wish this website
addressed how Kourtney got her groove
back ahold of what her face used to be
like hmm yeah now she's like because you
know I she's smiling she's like this
literally no that's so true like
something like and she definitely had
some work done like like anyone else you
know she did lose a lot of weight she
got really into working out with Khloe
right and I want to know what happened
mentally and physically to make that
transition possible it is such a good
that's the question I went into I don't
care how she gets ready for a big night
out now that she's like perfect look at
easy how did she become fresh as a daisy
great great and when she was so happy
being not totally remember those braids
get into the bangs out of our time and
she wore a lot of yellow yeah yeah
collars yes that was a hard time for
America when girls were wearing their
their hair and braids like they were
working on a farm but I also like loved
that house like just like aesthetically
like it was very like traditional like
colonial house and I just loved it but I
feel like that wasn't actually their
house because they never really showed
the real outside of their houses oh of
course not and yeah and then Scott like
got that bear that he carves it was just
a we yeah I can't live like we suffered
through it with that we have tried
interfering and people are saying she
eats natural that's why she looked so
good but she ain't naturally doing she
was bad yes she was she's been organic
forever yesterday I went to the store
with Snitch that's like a totally clean
store like they sell goop they sell
about upper teens like every natural
thing ever
and we wanted to get like some protein
smoothies and we wound up like looking
around they had a lot of CD and Finch
was saying like she needs CBD to put in
her coffee which makes no [ __ ] sense
like that is an oxymoron right cuz
coffee gives you energy and CBD mellows
you out right so why don't you just
neither and you'll feel okay you'll feel
balanced so I was like okay I will get
it for you if you put it in your tea or
do something that makes a little bit
more sense so we got like a couple
things some CBD chocolate is yeah and we
got maybe like and I got that Jade
roller wait that's so pretty
quartz roller because we when I was in
LA I went to Walker drawers to visit
Carolina's auto and they like we're
gonna be all there they're like brands
that they work with like Judy CBD I'm
like no they gave me like the CBD vape
pen and I was like in my hotel room
later that night I was like should I do
it but I didn't oh you should
anyways we got like four things and the
total was like 170 dollars I'm like I
was like just so nervous I was like what
store was this it was like a clean
market I think that's actually what it's
called the hell did you go it was just a
nearby it like we just wanted protein
smoothies right because we just worked
out so like we needed some person brave
and I was like I felt so awkward so I
was I just like cakes I was like I came
into goop store right I came to see
price and then snitch was like I used to
assume that everything was expensive but
it turned out no the CBD thing with $75
the one thing that snitch wanted so we
didn't get it
oh I really wanted to see if it worked
but we got these CBD chocolates that
then snitched on me and said it was the
most disgusting thing she's ever had and
she couldn't even eat it oh I don't know
it's not about the taste it's about what
the effectiveness after right but like
if you can't get it down right how are
you people like the drops look that you
just like dropping water or something
yeah well that's what she tried to get
but it was 70 something crazy yeah I was
like so awkward I didn't know how to be
like that is so awkward it was and I
can't ever go back there now well don't
worry we were like itemizing everything
except I did get the rose quartz roller
and I regret it like I feel like I moved
my brain around your brain does look
like off today no like I started doing
my fart head and then I had a headache
really yeah it was just like I went too
hard I think I did I move some stuff
around people say it's good for when
your puppy and your hangover
yeah the puffiness is legit you leave it
in your freezer I'm just gonna stick to
my vitamins cuz they've gotten me this
far they've taken care of you this far
hence Nate I've actually been off my
errands because I forgot to bring them
with me to my week-long trip in LA and I
got back on this morning and I feel like
I mean you can hear the nasality in my
voice like I'm just feeling my immune
system is feeling vulnerable because I
haven't been taking care of my body and
you haven't been listening to your body
right Sookie and I think bloggers as a
good vlog are you one always has to
listen to their body well with the
winter blues coming to an end it's
finally time to get back to a routine
that empowers you to feel your
healthiest give yourself an extra boost
to season whether you're looking for
more energy better sleep to maintain
stress or something else to help you
feel your healthiest care ups fun online
quizzes ask you about your diet health
goals and the lifestyle choices and
takes only five minutes to find out if
your eat personally scientifically back
to vitamin and supplement
recommendations we have a code for you
because we care about you guys for 50%
off your first month of personalized
care of vitamins go to take care
and enter code toast 50 so go to take
care of calm enter code toast 50 for 50%
off the first month of personalized care
of vitamins I've been on them now since
the beginning of the year and they
definitely feel the effectiveness at
most I feel the effectiveness because
I've been taking milk thistle which
helps with digestion I'm pooping like
five times a day also when I was in that
store I really realize like so many of
the brands that we work with on the toes
have really helped me like get in better
health and shape like are we wellness
experts yeah and I'm really glad for it
like so many of the things that I use
now are natural like I've been using
like obviously I switch to a natural
beauty last week I finally switch to
cope re because I was using literally
like Saks cuter and it wasn't enough
like all the chemicals my immunity had
gotten so high that a joke I have to
scale it back Chucky
literally me too and I now only use
natural deodorant and I don't do it
because like I care like Kourtney
Kardashian I just do it because like it
feels good and it's just like camping it
can't be good for me to be using men's
deodorant and still smell to be the code
for CBD no no I wish someone was nice I
mean they're like they're weird about
see me tea but Jul totally I'm not weird
I'm just scared I'm scared honestly I'm
gonna take my CBD chocolates tonight oh
my god will you give me one yeah
actually right now nothing like it's not
a drug it's just like caffeine it's the
caffeine of tiredness you know I always
sleep before bed it's a good thing to do
yeah it'll make you sleep better with me
I well I think I wanna go to bed like
eight o'clock tonight and then tomorrow
we'll find out if it worked okay okay
well let you guys know even though we're
acting like it's [ __ ] ambien and I'm
pretty sure it just like it's a piece of
chocolate yeah it's like a natural but
we're gonna find out okay next story
John Cena's mystery woman revealed days
after being spotted together during
night out in Vancouver this is so crazy
cuz Vicki fella is here
I almost said last Monday the WME the
WWE wrestler was spotted grinning
ear-to-ear as he held hands with a
smiling dark-haired woman who was
holding on to his arm from a fellow
wrestler to a Canadian engineer one week
after John Cena was spotted out and
about in Vancouver with a mystery woman
who identified her identity has been
revealed as che Sharia tada
Sharia tada currently works as a project
manager for a big Leone a Motorola
Solutions
tech company has been employed at the
vancouver-based companies in 2015 genius
who first confirmed her identity how did
they meet where did they no totally like
was she at SummerSlam I don't think so
what's so crazy is I started Wow
I've recently become really into total
Bella's just because it was like on
Sunday night and I just love a good
sister show like this one so now that
the season ended I was like I wanted to
go back to season one where did these
girls come from like I don't I want to
understand their dynamics right and I
like now having watched only season four
like Bri is like post-pregnancy and
always trying to get back into shape and
Nikki's the winning shape but apparently
wasn't always like that was it yes like
I just want to know how things started
so I started total Bella's season one
did you ever watch the season where
they're all living in John Cena's house
no I never watched Tony Bella's only
watched old divas Claudia
you have to just watch the first episode
they all move into John Cena's house and
he's the spirit all the whole family
why because Nikki broke her neck and she
needs people to help her and they're
also probably just got a reality show
and they need to be together she broke
her neck or chin neck surgery okay sorry
that's like really I think you die if
you break him neck surgery she couldn't
live so she couldn't drive okay because
she needed people to help her and also
they probably just got the reality show
contracts how fun we'll all live
together right except the house of John
Cena is so scary he's like a monkey like
how many rules yeah and every Friday
they have to have a dinner where they
all dress up and they keep saying they
wanted to be like Downton Abbey they
have this like weird obsession with
downstairs and it's like so weird like
I'm sorry John Cena you're not a part of
Downton Abbey no not at all but John see
that makes them have the dinner yeah
where they all get dressed up and it's
like they can't wear shoes in the house
but then so Brienne and her husband like
came into Downton Abbey dinner without
shoes on and they were like John Cena
and definitely weird great he's so crazy
and it's like why did we ever ship them
yeah no I used to watch and like he had
so many he's really scary and I feel
like this is the worst type of situation
like Nikki got him to settle down even
got him to get married but never won the
kids like I feel like now that he's like
been groomed like he's that we gonna
marry this girl that's always what
happens yes that was like when Justin
Sylvester was here but you're talking
about Dan Bilzerian for some reason why
because when Lynette Scavo was her I
said and all these officers came to her
house like totally armed and dangerous
everyone in the street thought it was
for Dan Bilzerian cuz she lives next
door to him she oh my god he makes how
much money oh my god he's well he was
already written now that's why he's
famous because of how rich he is and how
much he was spending his money right and
now he's like starting like a marijuana
company I was actually just looked at
this Instagram recently I don't know
what you were talking about him and how
he's actually really cute and
interesting no he's interesting I mean
that video with him running towards the
gunfire at route 51 like I will never
forget and now I love him forever but
but so we were saying like how Daniels
Justin was like who's he gonna marry and
it was like literally one day he's just
gonna wake up and it's like the first
girl who will come to him that will be
his right and that's what it's gonna
happen to John Cena ya know it's like
this girl doesn't even know the work
that Nikki Bella put in grooming John
Cena to be ready for this relationship
but then also this crazy thing about
John Cena is like he was so crazy with
all of his rules but every time Nicky
would confront him about something he
handled it in such like a mature way and
always admitted to the error of his ways
and wanted to change but it's like
walking on eggshells like it was though
he's literally a sociopath and it's like
we were all watching it on TV and then
he's also Ferdinand the bull I
understand how he was a bull right I
mean just the trajectory of a lot of WWE
stars career is so interesting like I
always forget the rock was like the og
John Cena right and the Hulk oh gee rock
with the Hulk no Hulk Hogan Coco it
always be hooking first or the whole car
Hulk Hogan probably the Hulk and then he
yeah you know it's just a weird number
like Brooke Hogan yeah and oh my god I
have a picture of me and Brooke Hogan in
Miami there you see the stress actually
there still is this restaurant called
Barton G's they actually went there on
the Kardashians it's like there's no
real food it's all like you get a piece
of fish in a cotton candy machine like
it's so [ __ ] stupid and me my friends
went there cuz it was like a hot spot
like at least his mom like got us a
reservation and we were like on spring
break and we went we saw Brooke Hogan
like she was like the Lindsay Lohan of
the time like me and my friend all know
like we [ __ ] like ran after and that's
her picture I'm like I actually saw the
picture and it's honestly like iconic
that's awesome yeah it was awesome it
was anyways I just can't believe John
Cena's back I'm a mess back dating
someone I mean this is actually
interesting time because Mickey Ballack
just announced that she's dating her
Dancing with the Stars partner right um
and they also launched a podcast heard
the partner heard the Bellas hurt the
Bella podcast we honest
makes a lot of sense what's a cult and
I'm literally such a big fat develop
podcast I'm such a big fan of them I
might actually listen to taka
I think they could have done better with
the name Isabela podcast it's me like
buzz and Bellas the Barden Bellas
yeah or like the Bella broadcast yeah I
know something with the letter B it's a
good letter we'll work on it and that
well yes I'm some ideas
so it's interesting suspect I mean he
looks really happy though yeah in this
picture of the surface of them like
what's with his hair that's how Ben
wears his hair like he's a changed man
even on GMA and like begged for her yes
and that he would have kids before I saw
this picture if you asked me what color
is John Cena's hair I would have said
he's bald now this picture his hair
looks so odd yeah it's like you got a
comb-over and hair plugs and he dyed it
black to match hers yeah
he just needs to be the man that like
this engineer like right maybe he's like
insecure cuz he's like fights for a
living like she's like an actual
accomplished engineer changing the world
maybe I don't know I just
I'm actually really I never thought I'd
say this that I'm really glad that John
Aniki aren't together their meat you
have to just watch epicene Mon okay Juan
Claudia a way it opens all you've so
much is the opening like shock toxic
like he yells at the mom for not making
her bed not yeah it was like you didn't
make your bed I'm Chuck
isn't that so weird totally okay next
story little like health news or lack
thereof measles count in u.s. [ __ ] are
already more than all of 2018 have you
read the have you heard about this
measles because people aren't getting
their vaccines measles cases in the US
have already searched past a total for
all of last year and it's only April
officials say member heyse associate not
use last month March with the number 5
no I said it on the patreon episode when
like I just every time I have to write
like March like if the date was like
March 31st I always write like 531
really yeah I also associate April with
the color green your freak
just associations are that I think are
interesting that are well interesting
people the toasters yesterday we're
doing all these posts like when it's
like nobody and then me yeah you want to
hear a ninja what CY Beck was gum okay
finished sorry about the measles sorry
the number of us measles cases
throughout through the first three
months of this year I have surpassed the
count for all 2018
they'll say there have been 387 cases
through March the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention reported Monday
there were 372 last year the numbers are
preliminary and may change but the 2019
tally is already the most since 2014
when 667 works say why this year's
numbers have been driven by outbreaks in
several states including New York no I'm
not feeling so well I don't know why but
like when I think measles I just get
like bumps all over your face like
that's is that true I don't I think it's
maybe that's how things are like huge
cysts like that's what I consider
measles California Illinois Texas
Washington most people who get measles
have not been vaccinated in the US most
at brakes are sparked by travelers who
picked up the virus from countries where
measles are more common
he's more common measles is singular
once again the anti-vaxxer it's just
like ruining our nation nearly 83,000
people contracted measles in Europe and
2018 highest number in a decade
according to the World Health
Organization the measles vaccine is 97
percent affected according to the CDC
measles is spread through the air when
an infected person coughs or sneezes but
so like if it is extremely contagious
I was vaccinated so let's see some of
the measles like licks my nose I'm fine
unless the three percent of the
vaccination kicks in the percent that
doesn't work yeah but it's the vaccines
still inside me like it's like it's like
a condom that's like 98% effective it
can still get pregnant technically okay
so if someone with measles comes and
looks my face I have a three percent
chance of getting it but someone who
doesn't has a 100 percent chance
yeah all right I like those odds yeah
okay like anything nothing's personal
sure yeah so it's just like I can't like
with with the anti-vaxxers I know you
really like are so anti just kind of
like fell into the conversation once I
don't know how you know what I was
watching
wall burgers that TV show about the
Wahlberg's and Jenny McCarthy was on
there saying how she's she's really like
a big spokesperson for anti-vaxxers and
that's how I first heard about it and I
just like started learning cuz I thought
it was interesting I feel like a good
amount of celebrities are sure to be
like a list they're all so good about
celebrities or Scientologists speaking
of Scientologists I'm going to
Clearwater Florida this weekend but the
Scientology headquarters are
headquartered
so feel free to grab tickets to my show
about girl with no job calm I'll be
hitting up Clearwater Florida which is
like the Tampa area
and then also Orlando which is like in
the Disney area no it's actually really
far but you know how hard it is to find
a hotel in Orlando that's not from
Disneyland cuz I'm like you should go
say in the Jojo Jackie it's like two
hours away I just googled like hotels in
Orlando all I get is Disney four seasons
of course it's crazy I know it looked
really nice but it's two hours away from
where I actually need to be I'm in
downtown Orlando oh I'm sorry
okay did the final story a little soon
news that's exciting for vegetarians and
kosher people Burger King joins the faux
meat trend with a new impossible whopper
this is like really major it's the first
fast-food joint that's gonna have a
vegetarian burger on the menu we're
gonna agree for you but what's the chain
it was Burger King oh [ __ ] we're gonna
have to go to Burger King which I
cleaned up before but actually so I know
Burger King rolled out a meatless
version I'm a signature whopper in 59
stores around st. Louis Missouri Monday
becoming the latest fast-food joint to
serve up plant-based patties that is so
cool a giant latest menu item will use
quote meat made by Silicon Valley
startup impossible foods and will cost
$1 more than the original whopper
reports reports Reuters wow that's a ton
reporters but isn't that weird though
the vegetables would cost more than me
no because I think that it takes a lot
more to engineer also I once had an
impossible burger and it was called it
was at I pick and was called the
impossible burger and it was just
vegetarian a veggie burger and I got and
I was like I'm sorry sorry you gave me a
hamburger I was like no it's the
impossible burger it's meant to taste
like meat I'm like there's no way this
is that you Terry that's what they're
gonna have a Burger King yes I'm so
excited I didn't know that impossible
burgers were a brand of burgers that are
vegetarian that are made to taste like
meat I was like sacked ASIS like this is
right hamburger right I mean I wonder if
I would like it it's like a comedy and I
literally I think I send it back so I
was like sir there's an thing they get
it all the time like it's so for sure
but now it just needs to be known that
impossible capital I is a brand of
veggie patties that are made to taste
like real meat do you think I would like
it I think student my cameras yeah I do
and then I think he might actually
loving it where the plant-based patty
which bleeds and sizzles yeah he's made
using an iron containing compound called
heat me do you think that it bleeds like
beet juice how do they make it bleed I
don't know
excited excited make it bleed actually
really do like hamburgers Burger King's
new whopper comes a middleweight amid a
wave of meatless burger options that
popular fast-food chains like what else
where do I get this burger how do I bet
for this burger Carl's jr. and Mike
Castle are both already selling beefless
patties but the meat substitutes
appearance at Burger King the second
largest hamburger chain in the US may
signal that the plant-based meat
replacements are ready to go mainstream
I think that they are I think it is so
crazy
McDonald's all they have is a [ __ ]
fish filet that's nasty
and most vegetarians won't even eat fish
and most legit harrion's when we need a
fish filet no Ben eats it and [ __ ]
loves it and it always sings a song I
ordered one in Nashville at what I now
know it was the height of my fatness
yeah because I ordered a fish fillet
give me back that fillet a fish give me
that fish hey that's a great Marshall um
and I think it's time to go a veggie
burger it doesn't even have to be
impossible if you don't want it there's
so many good veggie burgers out there
doctor Prague us Prague us craigers Boca
burger yeah no it's actually a Boca
burger at McDonalds it's also shocking
like that with the rise of like healthy
fast food like Chipotle being like a
huge chain like that they wouldn't even
attempt to move in the direction of like
plant-based goodness it's just like how
in first-class unless you preorder a
vegetarian meal there's no veg I
understand that they're not gonna have a
kosher meal for everyone or every
dietary need the in paleo but there
should be the tuber options of meat and
vegetarian
yeah just hair Ian was that mainstream
but no I apparently I'm weird you are no
but it's becoming much more popular but
not in first class on Delta flights
sorry not okay vegetarianism is like
popular I think in like coastal cities
like in real America like they just eat
whatever they want but it's like
vegetarianism covers so many bases
because I'm not a vegetarian I'm just
cochair so when I'm out I'm vegetarian
like and if you like a lot of other but
if you're out on a kosher restaurant
you'll eat meat yeah yeah but like on a
Delta flight
I'll eat vegetarian right it's just like
come on what about a risotto a pasta a
linguine with no clam linguini no clams
junk we need hold the plants and they
always made me feel like so crazy like
I'm asking for like the most like I
think it's so easy for a vegetarian
option anyways obviously Burger King
gets it I'm
go support Burger King when they're in
New York I'm [ __ ] going in it
possible let's go right now it's only in
st. Louis okay
guess one or two sweet little meet me in
st. Louis what are the other cities let
me see if I'm headed there on tour no
it's just st. Louis oh yeah I hopefully
seen Louis like the capital of
vegetarianism I don't know but hopefully
it goes well over there if you live in
st. Louis please water and impossible
burger and like if you don't even want
to eat it like you charge me on venmo
and I'll pay for it Joseph you'll regret
sighs to support actually I got a better
motor class like yeah broke college
student 60 bucks do you complete it no
yeah I'm so ever since like everyone
sent Becca kufran money for drinks after
she was like dumped I'm over like people
been marching or or requesting same I
think it's like nah yeah the jokes over
so um yeah please don't anyway he's back
the filet-o-fish give me that fish eh
was that real story that was our last
story let's talk let's do it Mass this
it was a good episode better than the
past few we've had I believe oh yeah and
I just want to say something
controversial that this season stinks
yes we had four episodes in the lead up
to Mexico which never happens on a Bravo
show it was weird its lead up and then
trip and it's because there is a dearth
of content and they they're trying to
make something out of nothing in a lot
of episodes and and I have like in this
episode specifically I had a lot of
feelings about the future of the show
yeah and that it can't keep going the
way that it is and they build this
season as the Vanderpump rules go
somewhere they've never been adulthood
and no they're supposed to be going to
adulthood and they're not and they just
keep drinking for the show and they're
ruining their own lives like Stasi
drinking and the show she is destroying
her licensure relationship and if she
wasn't if she didn't have to go on this
trip for the show and like keep drinking
all day like she wouldn't have gotten to
that place and it's like even Katie and
Tom like oh my god it's really making me
sad it's like the the dedication that
they have to give to the show are
destroying the lives that they built for
them totally that's such a good point
Lala yeah even though lolly I feel like
he's like I'm a different generation in
terms of like she's like the nouveau and
like James Kennedy by but she's kind of
transcendent into like an OG Brittany
and her stomach so oh yeah so stupid
like she can't not drink on this
otherwise what is she doing there right
but like she says an ulcer totally it's
really also they're just like making
mountains out of molehills it's like
they're all getting drunk of having like
dumb arguments that they forget about
the morning in the morning but they're
making them have it out Stassi and
Bullock's staying up all night going
through this conversation whereas
normally they would probably just go to
sleep and wake up and get over because
it wasn't a real fight but they're
making them all drink they're having
like heightened drunk arguments that
aren't real and pretending like that's
real life right and it's not know and
it's not enjoyable to watch these people
that you've grown to love like over
seven years like watching the tree
rectory like Sassy's life and her
boyfriends enough she's finally with
bone like we can all agree they're so
cute together he's so great for her and
like we just want the best for them and
it's like but being in this Vanderpump
hamster wheel it's it's self-destructive
and it's like I don't want to see that
about this character that I love who's
coming out with a book could we talk
about Lala being naked on the terrace
with Tom Schwartz and Tom Sandoval
unbelievably inappropriate because it
was wasn't two years ago that la la like
flashed her tits at the waterfall and
Katie was freaking out and now Katie's
sitting with her tits out too and she's
getting a beer from Tom Schwartz with
her tits out and it's like yet she's
it's crazy
what exceptions you'll make for people
that you like and and totally for people
that you don't like and she's
unbelievably cool for allowing that I
would never never
especially as long as like the most
perfect kids ever well they were all
skinny-dipping and I was just like
looking at all of their bodies first of
all they all look incredible they're
only cannibal and I love how they were
all wearing underwear except for Kristen
and neither was Lala oh maybe it was
Lala
no Christine was wearing underwear so
also the port of Ayrton oceans are very
choppy like I don't think they're known
for their beaches so when Christine are
in their drunken that's why they were
like everyone hold hands I think they
knew that it was the dumbest thing that
they could terrible idea drunk and not
just drunk swimming which is always a
bad idea but like choppy oceans drunk
and you know I mean I think Shana is so
boring but like no I wouldn't have gone
in either no and who else are Arianna
Arianna being wasted like just talking
in circles on the porch was so funny it
was so real I like drunk Arianna that's
interesting
me too and I was when Arianna called
Ballet aside to like scold her I was so
glad that Lila DoubleDown me too I mean
I'm Malala apologizer so I even if she's
wrong I don't see it but in this
instance and with the whole Raquel
James Billy thing I am so unless I do
what everyone fails to mention is that
they were talking about her dad right
and she overheard it and then they made
her feel crazy like she heard something
that she did right there it's like
everyone's glazing over just a small
detail about the things that they said
to ignite her into being so crazy like
you can't react like that actually when
someone talks about your father in
general let alone your father he just
passed away
you could react to her the [ __ ] walls
right and so Lala's only crime was
yelling in the workplace not the things
she said and not who she said them to
the crime was yelling in the workplace
which you know we've all been guilty of
at some point especially I'm Andrew
pepper oils the picture that Tom said
I'm also a Kushina was actually really
good no I know
I slipped amazing when she was like
starting in like Adams writing he looks
she looks hot like that's boring yeah
and not interesting and boring when Jack
said he still had feelings for sake I
was crying I feel like they feel like
they have to have like these drugs
because they really got so popular
getting wasted
throwing the chunky sweaters off beating
each other up Kristen slap a Stassi
stopping Kristen they feel like that's
the level that they have to achieve to
make the show good but in reality then
just sitting around and joking like Jax
being like I still have feelings feel
like that is funny in that was the best
part of the episode like not the drunk
stupid fighting right that's obviously
forced right and like it's like they
just drink and see what happens like
that's a the template for the show so I
went to watch happens live afterwards
and it wasn't on the head of that and
primp real special and it made me really
depressed and I turned it off because
everyone was being so mean to Jax and
it's like here's okay but no that's just
what inning you know when I go under it
clip they did like 10 M and then I was
thinking about Jax and I was like to all
of these seasons in Jax has said if
you've read interviews with him it's
very clear that yes he did a lot of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] but he was also doing it
in the name of the show right but his
character has now grown in matured and
this is the face that he's in where he's
just being a doting fiancee he could
find me like live his life with Brittany
the way that he wants cuz he's cycled
out of being the villain right and now
the show is boring because of it and I
feel like as much as Jax hate James
Jackson Durst and that is necessary for
James to be on these trips and to be at
boys night
we're in order for the show to be
interesting like Jax can't always be the
[ __ ] like there's me and Jax actually
can't be the [ __ ] anymore because it
won't work for the show otherwise then
Brittney will have to break up with it
right
and that people need to grow up like the
audience enjoy seeing Jackson Britney
being engaged yeah Jane like there needs
to be a villain it is James and he
should be on these trips and the girls
are like not understanding the business
of the show right no totally because
it's just like dealt with so much [ __ ]
for so long
yeah scene I'm watching up inside that's
a bad clip on watch happens I was really
sad they used to be so mean to him
but I really did like it was like a 30
minute episode where they just went back
on every time the cast has been on watch
opens live and the most interesting part
was that hold on at this means you can
mute my mic one sec thank you which I
didn't know is that in season two when
they were filming they found out that
Jax and Kristen [ __ ] and who found out
the crew the cast like they were filming
currently and they booked Jackson Stassi
I'm watched rappin's live and nobody
knew that they weren't together anymore
and that this whole thing that come out
so Stassi had her back towards him the
whole time they were being stony to each
other and he's like now we look back
watching the interview knowing that
Stassi had just found out that he [ __ ]
Kristen and it's so awkward oh my god
that's why those little like the
episodes are interesting yeah but I
actually was looking forward to a live
episode of watch out inside but I guess
they meet you our union which everyone
was saying was so dramatic
I read the fakest speaking of my new
segment of steak headlines yeah I write
an article exclusive page six that
Vanderpump rules caste is divided after
the reunion yeah because when they went
to Caesars palatte yeah for Lisa
Vanderpump yeah they went to the date
like a pool and James and marquel and a
friend were at one Cabana and everyone
else was at the other like that's not
the Vanderpump rules cast abided that's
how things are now I thought it was
gonna be like Lala right no guys I
should have been there umbrellas group
is divided the same it's always been
right
reunion changes nothing for Vanderpump
whirls crew I didn't really realize I
don't think until like the last month
like how wealthy Lisa Vanderpump is like
owning a restaurant in LA I mean in
Vegas like is as a restaurant or like
the highest level like it's easy money
that that restaurant will now and
forever like make millions of dollars
for this event apartment not everyone
can get that no I don't know and it's
weird that she keeps saying 30 something
restaurants like you don't know how many
restaurants you've opened right and it's
like how many do you open
excuse me now yeah I don't care about
the previous 30 the 30 something just it
was the second time I'd heard it she
said it last night
um and it's like I don't know if I was
opening restaurants I think I keep I
keep count duh like and thirtysomething
is a lot of restaurants to have open but
it's not like a number like a Google
building and the tum tum bullshitter II
like I just can't care I can't care
except Tom Hammonds really popping off
like Miley was there and Selena Gomez
yeah I really it's really become a hot
spot good firm that's what it should be
right but I just like hate that Lisa
Vanderpump's a part of reality TV is
really like per minute per meeting the
celebrity world total you know what it's
like if Jennifer Lawrence is going out
in LA like she's gonna go to town town
right so they did a whole thing on
Jennifer Lawrence on the thing last
night and it was really funny and she
had great insight on Jeana I just it's
like I'm really happy that all the
celebrities are like loving Tom Tom but
like it's annoying I can't explain no it
is annoying and it's all and it all ends
up in the pocket of Lisa Vanderpump
which makes it the most annoying except
the Tom see a five percent I'm happy for
them me too but like um I should love
the Tom's like they always like we have
been great on the show I never
personally related to them um but I just
feel like they've been extra great and
they've really been such troopers with
Lisa totally but I'll like really never
be able to wrap my head around the fact
that like Lisa gifted this restaurant to
them and Tom Schwartz never worked at
Sur and he really got on the show just
for being Katie's husband and like he
bartend and once that pump it had a
panic attack and he's great for the show
whatever but it's like there are a lot
of people who continuously like work but
I guess you really did it for Katie
because like Katie's her favorite she
but Tom Tom and like I get I get why
Lisa Vanderpump did it but it's like Jax
Jack bled out for the show everyone in
the world hates Jax that I know it's
really sad for Jax and like she could
have made a restaurant called The
Witches of WeHo that was like a spooky
jekyll-and-hyde restaurant no she
[ __ ] hates Kristen the fact that she
was on the phone with Tom Sandoval and
he was just talking about nothing and
she found a way to bring up Kristen take
one of Kristen's to chill pills yeah
what does that have to do with anything
she's like obsessed with Chris she's
obsessed with hating Kristen it makes it
drives me crazy and even though like
even when I on Kristen's worst day like
I still take her side over Lisa
Vanderpump she was being like so
annoying last night with Mexican Google
series oh it's just she was many books
was about why was she being such a freak
I don't know she's like appears to be on
drugs I mean she was
whatever the Spanish word for butterfly
is that's my new alter-ego Mehdi posa
hey no that was really stupid they
really are just like struggling to throw
the time blocks why total it made me so
angry like that's it that's like someone
who says like my spirit animals a koala
you know people who are still saying
spirit animals like Nietzsche shop you
know like soon she's gonna come out with
the James May t-shirt that says better
ethos that is my spirit all right it's
gonna be a go find your own butterfly I
really wanna vomit
okay well it's 11:30 one so we've got a
minute over Oh
anything else you want to chat about um
I mean I would like to let you know that
this episode is brought to you by
Skillshare and then if you're not on
Skillshare you're just not educated and
I don't want to talk to you because
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
25,000 classes in design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fill your curiosity creativity and
career and you know what I'm a big class
or in these days and going on class
tonight
yeah driving because I'm really enjoying
bettering myself a Skillshare how to
drive the class you know I would be
there in the mean which skill show
classes are you taking
well you know I've been taking my
Photoshop class oh yeah it has been
going really well I still don't feel
like an expert because I I just am not
really everything but just like our
business it's like so technologically
advanced it's like I'm not so I've
really been enjoying my classes that's
so interesting about you guys learned
has your amnesia gotten any better no I
did mobile photography and I feel as if
my Instagram flow has been the major
benefactor of that class I love to hear
it yeah and lifelong learning is
important to me in every facet of life
because you just never want to be sad
you want to keep growing and now that
we're not in school to learn like boring
[ __ ] and I realized what one of the
toasters told me what the trial was the
evolution this member I'm sorry the
Scopes Monkey Trial does that ring a
bell no more how about this name
Clarence Darrow nope never heard of him
okay well finish anyways you can join
the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
right skill for skill share is offering
toast listeners two months of unlimited
access to over 25,000 classes both free
to sign up go to skill share
calm / morning toast again go to
Skillshare calm / morning toast it
started two months now
that's Skillshare calm / morning toast I
love being American camber when I'm
doing a greens so we have a siesta -
Elly 3 we have just to keep an early
tonight we have I'm not caught up
because uh MTV is no longer on DirecTV
and my login doesn't work oh my god
really
that's crazy I can't get into them TV
app to watch shows but we get screeners
but I have to watch them on my computer
and they say screen or on top okay fine
so I was premium as [ __ ] I want it I
mean Beverly Hills or New York tonight
oh forget that really Hills okay wow
that's gonna be good this is a screaming
episode where they're screaming in
Lisa's kitchen oh my god yeah oh my god
I'm so excited they can banter from todd
comes out with his finger
oh so I have a controversial opinion
which is that they're billing New York
housewives all the commercials historic
greatest showmen this is the greatest
show which is like a bull today and they
never use mainstream music and
commercials so like they paid a lot from
you guys and saying then yesterday's
commercial it said something like this
is the greatest show on in the history
in history and I just want to say like
so far this season is one of the worst
we've ever had bleak as hell yeah it's
one of the worst in a while considering
it's been so good sucio Lee Keough
Scopes Monkey Trial okay I don't know
what that was Tennessee back in the day
I 1900 like a 1900 story when
evolutionism was really up for debate up
for debate and really taking you know
people were really starting to get into
it but you know down south where people
were very much on creationism because
that's very well my my camera watch this
news because they were all of
creationism they accused of teacher of
teaching evolution in schools and
apparently I was reading on Wikipedia so
maybe it's true maybe it's not the
teacher was actually in on this when
they when they were gonna put him on
trial for teaching in schools he never
did it but he admitted to doing it so
that this trial could get nationwide
press and it just became a template for
one like evolution versus creationism as
debated in a court of law which is weird
and too just for courts of law I'm not
gonna lie I understand 0% of what you
just said I think I need to make you
watch the Scopes funny oh no get away
from everybody what do you think what so
much
to bring you back what if you watch
Scopes Monkey Trial and as long as that
is I'll watch episodes of friends
honestly no that's how much I don't want
to watch it I think you could learn
something I'm not interested in learning
I'm on Skillshare [ __ ] thank you guys
for watching the morning
host millennial Morning Show me go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube and we're also available
as a podcast feel free to come see me on
tour meeting up Clearwater in Orlando
this weekend so that's girl with no job
home for tickets and that's all I got
anything you want to show yes I just
want to say justice for this time I'm
gonna stand up to show you that it's
actually cute oh and you can always
follow me
I've Jackie O problems where we're a
cute outfits like this one with my M
Jimmy shoes thank you guys we'll see you
tomorrow
you